[Music]
everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm today we're gonna be
continuing our study on middle game
strategies so far we've touched on
opening close games have to tell from
pawn structure for game is open or
closed and then how to play accordingly
and last video we touched on what
signifies a good Bishop and what
signifies a bad Bishop and how to play
accordingly and today we're going to be
going over outpost created by pawns up
the board and how to play accordingly so
if you look at this board there's two
pawns that you want to look at and right
off the bat you should see this b5 and
this g5 Square have really good outpost
in the c6 and the f6 squares and
basically if you can occupy a square
with a piece that is less valuable than
any of your opponent's pieces that can
capture it this can lead to a huge
strategic advantage so if you can put a
minor piece on this Square and black
doesn't have a piece that can capture it
obviously none of the black's pawns can
capture it and black doesn't have a
minor piece to capture it so anything
that he would capture with would be of
greater value so if we just look at it
from here if white moves his knight to
c6 which is protected by the the b5
square here this is a great outpost for
the knight he can at any time you know
move and attack any other squares but no
piece can make him move so he can just
hang out here and apply tons of pressure
obviously you can see all the squares
he's attacking already on the black side
but black can't do anything about this
if you were to attack this piece it
would have to be with one of his rooks
and obviously white would gladly trade
away his knight for a rook
another key square you you probably
already saw is moving their Bishop to f6
protected PI the g5 square and on f6
it's another great outpost there's
nothing black can do to move this bishop
and the bishop has great attacking lines
against black and there's not much more
I can do why it's gonna have a very good
game especially if they move both of
them if white also brings his knight
here there's nothing but I can do to
fend these pieces off and why it's gonna
have a very good game so in any game you
want to look at the pawn structure that
you have and see if there's any outpost
that you can put your minor pieces your
Knights or your bishops into a place
where your opponent will be unable to
force them off so we're gonna go ahead
and take a look at a real-life example
in a game played and see what to look
for in the game all right go ahead and
take a look at this example here and see
where you think white should play and
where white eventually wants to go you
can take a minute pause the video if you
want to but just take a look at why its
position here
and hopefully you saw that eventually
white is gonna want to come to the d6
square it's a great outpost for for
white no piece of black of equal or
lesser value can capture this obviously
you see the black Bishop is on a light
square so he can't move the knight and
all blacks other pieces are much more
valuable than the knight and so why it's
night can just hang out here so
eventually what White's gonna want to
play is Knight to d2 to e4 to d6 and as
you'll see there's not really much black
can do about it
this d6 square is gonna be a great
outpost for us so if we look at it our
first move is obviously going to be d2
and black would like to try to kind of
open up his game once we get to the d6
square it's really gonna cramp black
down this d7 Square is going to be a
huge weakness because it's kind of kind
of block off both sides of blacks attack
these pieces are gonna have a hard time
working together because they're so
cramped in they're not gonna have a lot
of space so black would like to just
simply bring maybe his pawn to b5 bring
his bishop into the action maybe put his
bishop on c6 defending the d7 square
which is a weakness and just getting his
Bishop into the game but as you see
after b5 and we bring our Knight to e4
black can no longer just play as bishop
to b7 because we can just fork his
Bishop with check here so that's not
going to work and after d2 black cannot
simply defend this e4 square with his
pawn to d5 because of on passant we can
just take his pawn right there so if we
come to d2 and black tries to go to b5
and then once we come to e4 black tries
to come to the c7 square with his queen
protecting the b7 square of this bishop
we can continue what we were going for
put our knight on the same outpost check
the king the
is gonna have to move to f8 if he moves
to da we can simply fork the rook on h8
so he can't do that so he's gonna have
to move to FA and then simply here we
can take the bishop on c8 and the ca was
defending this d7 pawn so after black
takes we can now capture on the d7
square and if black captures we can
obviously recapture with our rook and
we're gonna be up a pawn which is great
and any in game if you're up a pawn that
usually bodes well for you so if you
look at that blacks black has trouble
trying that so he may try something else
if we go to d2 he made this completely
scratch move in the pawn and trying to
expand he may just cancel on the King
side obviously we're going to continue
with our attack here to e7 and now we
may see like try to bring his Queen to
the c7 square and then once we have our
outpost here we may see black come to
the g7 square to put added pressure on
the d7 so obviously we solve it once we
take we have two attackers on the d7
square so this right here allows black
to defend the seven square but if you
look at it all of black's pieces black's
rook on a eight isn't doing anything and
all three of these pieces for black are
all defending this d7 square and why
it's not having to do too much and you
can see the amount of pressure that this
knight on d6
is having blacks having to use all of
his pieces to defend this d7 square
blacks not anywhere close to attacking
white and what we can do here is since
black is completely cramped is we can
start to attack on the King side we can
bring our rook to the f3 Square
eventually we can bring our our Queen
over to the e4 square we can bring our
Queen over to the the g6 square once we
get our rook over to the g3 square
blacks gonna have a real hard time it's
going to take black a lot of moves to
try to come to the Kings side to protect
and at the same time this this Knight is
really given black a lot of problems
it's cramping them down
you can't take it without giving up a
lot of material and so why it has a huge
advantage obviously you see right here
we have the same material advantage but
just from putting this night on this
outpost of these six White has a huge
huge advantage and black is gonna
basically crumble as we just completely
annihilate them on the King side so in
any game it's very very important
whether it be a bishop or Knight or any
other minor piece to look at a great
outpost for your pieces especially as
your pawns move up the board try to find
a good outpost and see if you can get
there and once you do see how you can
attack from that outpost and if not hey
you may just want to leave it there and
just apply pressure like this Knights
doing this Knights not attacking anyone
right now
but it's applying a lot of pressure and
black can't really move anywhere so
another key concept just to keep them on
when you're playing chess hope this
video helps along with the others I
obviously have a ton more hopefully I'll
start making them a little sooner
together but thanks for watching I've
had a lot of great feedback we've only
been up for about a month and we already
have over a hundred and twenty
subscribers so I thank you guys if you
haven't subscribed please do got a lot
of great more stuff coming out and if
you haven't checked out the website
www.hsn.com